DON DODGE: Hi, I'm Don Dodge.
And this is Google Root Access.
Today, my guest is Ryan Damico,
founder and CEO of Crocodoc.
Welcome, Ryan.
RYAN DAMICO: Thanks, Don.
DON DODGE: So I met you about
six years ago in Boston.
And at the time, you were
doing this web annotation thing
that you called Crocodoc.
So tell me about how you
started, first of all?
RYAN DAMICO: Sure.
So I started the company
out of my dorm room at MIT.
And back then we called
ourselves WebNotes
because we were building note
taking software for students.
And it was a classic
case of the startup that
solves a problem because
they think it's really cool,
and obviously, the world's
going to come and buy it
once it's out.
So we spent a good two
to two and a half years
building this
really good product
for creating highlights
and sticky notes
and other types of annotations
in your web browser,
and we were so convinced that
everyone was going to love it.
But we made the classic mistake
of solving a non-problem.
We had a really well
executed product
that nobody cared about.
So that was the very first
innovation of the company.
DON DODGE: Was is that
they didn't care about it
or that they
wouldn't pay for it?
RYAN DAMICO: That's
a good question.
Well, A, we were
selling to students,
and that's a hard
thing to do regardless.
But the more important issue
is that we weren't solving
a really burning,
hair on fire problem.
We were building a set of
features that were really
perceived as nice to haves.
DON DODGE: So it was a
vitamin, not a pain killer.
RYAN DAMICO: Exactly, and we
learned that the hard way.
DON DODGE: Interesting.
And how did you pivot from that,
or did you do several pivots
from there to where
you are today?
RYAN DAMICO: Well, there
was a main pivot when
we had spent a couple years
building this product,
and we saw that it
was getting some use,
but the growth was really flat.
And we had added a
couple features, tested
some hypotheses, and
nothing was really
moving the needle too much.
So right around that time,
we were running out of money
as a startup.
We almost imploded as a company.
We made a whole bunch of
mistakes as a startup.
And then just as we pulled
up before hitting the ground,
we moved from Boston
out to Mountain View
and went through Y Combinator.
And that's when we started
trying bigger experiments
with the product.
And the one that led to Crocodoc
was taking this one feature
from our product called WebNotes
where you could upload a PDF
file to your web browser, view
it in a Flash Player we built,
and then actually highlight
it and add annotations to it.
That was the thing people
seemed to like the most.
So we ripped that out of
WebNotes in a weekend.
We re-branded it as Crocodoc.
And we repositioned it
not as an academic tool
but as a way to
collaborate with coworkers
and actually annotate
presentations and documents
to get work done.
And that's where
we started to see
some real traction and some
interest in the product.
DON DODGE: So tell me
about Y Combinator.
Or let me ask this question.
Do you think you would have
gotten to the same point
and done the same pivot on
your own back in Boston,
or did it take being in
the Y Combinator community
and in that cauldron of
ideas to get you there?
RYAN DAMICO: I think
it certainly helped.
Y Combinator was a
catalyst, for sure.
And being surrounded by a
whole bunch of other startups
that were facing similar
issues, that really
helped to zoom out and get
some perspective in what we
were doing.
And just moving the
company, across the company,
we needed a big change
like that, metaphorically.
So we did that.
It caused us to reassess
what we were doing.
If we hadn't, maybe we would
have come up with this change.
But it would have taken
a longer time at least.
DON DODGE: So I did a show a
few weeks ago about accelerators
and incubators and why you might
consider joining an incubator
and what you give up in equity.
What was your experience at Y
Combinator, and in retrospect,
do you think it was a
great decision to do?
RYAN DAMICO: Yeah,
in retrospect,
it was definitely
a great decision.
I don't think we would've made
it as a company had we not gone
through Y Combinator, just
because when we started off
we were very naive
entrepreneurs.
We were just heads
down, building
things we thought were
cool, which is really
not the best way
to build a product.
So the best thing,
again, was just
being surrounded by those
other companies who,
some had faced similar problems.
Some were more advanced and
farther along than we were.
But just getting to
see that perspective
and see that we weren't alone
in going through those struggles
and learning from
others in terms
of how they had dealt
with those problems,
that was by far the most
beneficial aspect of it.
DON DODGE: So it was beneficial,
and the equity that you gave up
didn't matter in the
scheme of things.
RYAN DAMICO: It didn't.
At first, we were really
hesitant-- oh, man, we
don't want to give up
these points of equity.
But looking back, it should've
been such a no-brainer for us
because we were debating
whether to give up
a few points of equity for a
company that was just headed
straight in a nosedive
for the ground.
So it was really
worth it for us,
and it was a fun
experience, too.
DON DODGE: Awesome.
So you did some
pivots from being
a consumer-facing freemium
app to an enterprise app.
So that's where you are today.
How did you get there?
RYAN DAMICO: Sure.
Well, there's one more key
pivot that nobody expected,
which is that once we had this
Crocodoc product where we were
letting people collaborate
on PDFs and other documents
online, we made the decision
that, in order for us to be
successful, we had
to build the best
online viewer for
documents in the world.
Because unlike
images and videos,
documents don't really
work natively on the web.
So we saw that as
an opportunity.
And we spent another
several years
actually ditching
everything we built in Flash
and recreating
everything in HTML5.
We wanted a faster,
lighter weight experience.
We wanted to get
onto mobile devices.
So we made a big
technology decision
and made a big bet on that.
And it really paid off.
And the surprising thing
is that, once we actually
figured out we could actually
display Office and PowerPoint
and PDF documents in
pure HTML in your web
browser and your
mobile device, we
were going to use that
in our own product.
But before we could
recycle the technology back
into the company, we
started getting approached
by other companies
who saw what we built.
And they said, hey, I like what
you're doing-- don't really
care for this businessy
product, but can we
embed the technology
in our own products?
And that was the major pivot
that led us to the success
that we saw and eventually
became very profitable
doing as a company.
So we actually licensed this
out, hosted a web-based SAS
API, and partnered
with companies
like Yammer, LinkedIn,
Facebook, Dropbox, SAP,
all these companies who use
this in their own services,
so that their users could see
documents in their own web
apps.
And that's what took off.
DON DODGE: So you
generated revenue early
from that relationship.
RYAN DAMICO: We did.
Totally unexpected,
but it turns out,
especially when you're
selling to enterprises,
you've got to have the best
product, 10 times better
than anything else.
And as a startup, what we
learned, again the hard way,
is that you've got
to find a problem, A,
you can solve better
than anyone else but, B,
that's narrow enough in
scope that you can solve it.
We were just a
seven-person company,
and we were able to carve
out this niche for us
where we build the best
online document viewer, which
is a very specific
kind of technology.
But sure enough,
we did it so well
that other companies
couldn't not take notice,
and it really helped
us with our sales.
DON DODGE: So how do you
convince a big company
to buy a product
from a tiny startup?
RYAN DAMICO: It's not easy.
It's not easy.
You've got to win on
product, for starters.
So if you don't have
the best product,
I don't think
you've got a chance.
If you've got the best product,
then you have a chance.
And for us, it helped
by really identifying
who was going to evangelize
us at the target company.
So we worked with
folks, for instance,
at Yammer who really believed
in what we were doing,
saw the value for the
users, and worked with us.
And as a startup, what
we did is just really
partnering with that person
and asked a lot of questions
about how we're
perceived, functionally
what do we have to do--
pricing is always difficult
when you're starting off.
How is pricing perceived?--
and really built
up a great rapport.
So we were just
asking questions,
getting direct feedback,
and adapting the technology
in the business that
we were offering
to suit the needs
of the customer.
DON DODGE: And how did
you target your customers?
How did you find them?
RYAN DAMICO: That's
a good question.
We were really lucky in
that most of our customers
all came to us.
It's a really small
world out there.
When we did our first
integration with Yammer
and that went live,
it went really well.
It allowed users of Yammer to
upload all sorts of documents
and actually view them and
then collaboratively add
highlights and comments
in Yammer's product.
And for Yammer, this brought
users out of their inbox
and actually created a
whole new workflow on Yammer
which was really successful.
A lot of other companies
took notice of this.
And then soon enough,
we were working
on resumes for LinkedIn,
internal presentations for SAP,
and all sorts of interesting
applications like that.
So we just were approached
by lot of companies.
DON DODGE: Wow.
Great story.
Well, that's all we
have time for today.
Thank you for joining us.
As a Google Root
Access viewer, we're
offering a $2000
credit on Google Cloud.
So if you'd like to develop
applications in the cloud,
get a $2000 credit
to get started.
The details are on your screen.
Thank you very much for joining
us, and see you next time.